hi everyone welcome to my presentation
in the frame of the genetics virtual
week by lab roots
my name is matthias donoa i am a
resource associate
in zachary liemann's group at
cosplaying cardboard laboratory in new
york and i'm going to talk today about
our
recent research and we're interested in
the contribution of transposons
in structural evaluation and philosophy
diversity in tomato
so my presentation today will follow uh
two main parts so in the first part of
the talk
i will describe our most recent data
about the study of the landscape of
structural variation in tomato
and on the second part i will provide
the characterization of the transposon
family that is involved in structural
variation in tomato
so what do we mean when we speak about
structural evaluation well structural
variation
refers to large-scale structural
differences that are found
in organism genomes
and usually these variants are found uh
as highly polymorphing with new species
so structural variants
are made of deletions or in session of
novel dna sequences
they can be due to tandem duplication uh
internal duplication
as well as induction and translocation
so
search important free arrangement
of the genomic dna has
the potential for for real geometric
change in dna organization
and it might have major impact on the
biology of the genomes and the way the
genome functions and indeed structural
variants have been associated with
a lot of pathogenic conditions
in humans by example so several cancers
as well
as alzheimer's or autism have been
associated with
structural variation uh
in in a large number of cases
but structural variants are not only
found in humans and of course you can
also also be associated with
different uh process and behaviors
uh in other species such as fish in
drosophila
as well as bacteria or yeast
structural variation is particularly
important because
uh it is associated with uh evolution
of the genome it's also evolution of the
behaviors of the organism
and presented here very interesting case
of
behavior change or evolution in the
behavior of animals
associated with structural variation in
this case
i'm showing that the adaptation of
dogs to
having the ability to to rely on human
footstraps
uh to to to be eaten
and especially the ability of of modern
dose to be able to process
starch is actually linked to an increase
in gene copy number
of the genes that are able to produce
the enzymes responsible for degradation
of starch
and structural evasion being this at the
basis
of the evolution of phenotypes
it's also particularly true in plants
where structural variation was actually
instrumental during crop domification
i'm showing here three different
examples of how structural variations
actually enabled
the identification domestication and
selection
of traits that were important for for
plant domestication in breeding
i'm showing here the fact that the loss
of the
shattering which is that dispersed the
ability of the plant to disperse its own
seeds
for survival so the loss of the
shattering which is a trait that is
really important for modern agriculture
uh has actually been acquired through
suture variation happening in genes that
are involved
in the shattering of of the feet so that
was true
in in in sorghum but also in other plant
species such as rice
where similar structural variants was
involved in
a loss of function of of a gene involved
in
in shattering and
another striking example is also the the
improved ethical dominance
seen in maize which is due to the
incision of the transposable elements
up upstream a gene that is involved in
the regulation of the architecture
of the plant so all together
they are compelling examples of
structural variation being able to
create new phenotypes and to provide a
huge diversification
um in phenotype foods and organisms so
in the lab we're interested
in a plant crop
which is very important being one of the
most economically important plants in
the world which is tomato
and tomato as well shows
a lot of traits that have been
influenced by structural variation
i'm showing here three different cases
in which
the fruit features have been influenced
by structural variation
the first example is the fruit shape
that has been
heavily influenced by structural
variation and here in this case the
elongation of the fruit
has been linked to the occurrence of a
31 kb dilution in the promoter of this
gene or fp20
that confers this elongated fruit
phenotype
second is the fruit weight with
tomato accessions that are showing
increase in fruit weight
are actually associated with a large 1.5
kb deletion
uh in the fruit weight
candidate 11.3 and last is the increase
in local number local number
are actually the compartment where the
seeds reside within smart fruits
and in this case a large-scale
chromosomal inversion
resulted in a change in gene expression
that facilitated the increase
in number of the thick compartment
within the product
so i've just shown that structural
variation have actually fueled
phenotypes
that were actually relevant for plant
biology evolution and agriculture
but nevertheless the causative molecular
mechanisms
are not really well known and appears to
be very diverse and largely and
characterized
therefore it's particularly relevant to
understand
how structural variation can provide and
diversify
phenotypes that would be of agronomical
interest and by looking
and understanding how structural
variation works we might be able to
harness the structural evaluation
to actually improve uh
our current crops to make them more
resilient for
the uh fastly changing environment
so what's our approach um the idea here
is to characterize the landscape of
structural variation with that with that
within our favorite
uh crop model plan which is tomato so to
do that
we undergo a very large sequencing
effort
by uh sequencing using long grid
sequencing technology
a hundred diverse tomato expressions the
idea here was to
capture a large breadth of structural
variation
to identify the structural variants and
to classify them based on the feature
and then
assess their consequences on phenotypes
so i'm showing here a phylogeny which
has been uh which is based on on
snips uh over thousands
of tomato genomes
and what you can see here following the
different colors are
the different tomato toxins with uh
selective normally copercicum
being the more than tomatoes and then
moving slowly towards
early domesticates such as cellular
normally compassionate for me
and one species such as surrendering to
mania
sonoma cancer and fernandinho
we sampled within the thousands of
actuation
a hundred of tomato accessions that
we're covering
the entirety of the phylogeny in order
to capture as many
structural variants as possible
so the hundred times oxygen selected
contained forty five sonum lycopesicum
23 um
surname nicole pacquicon syracuse gates
and then twenty five seventeen penitent
six random graph i can see functional
cheese mania
that make the wild total species
in our in our dataset here we sequence
them
uh using the oxford nanopore long grid
technology with minion and mostly from
ethereum
in order to have a
huge quality and a high quantity of good
data
to look for structural variation
so then using this data we called the
structural variation against our
referent genome
using sniffles and identified
all the 230 000 structural variants
within the hundred genome
so we're providing here the first tomato
pan
sv genome and what the
graph you can see here shows is actually
showing the number of
structural variants found per
accession on the x-axis so what you can
see
is that most of the accession we are
looking at here are showing actually
several
thousands of structural variants
and such as their variants as you can
see from the features on the right hand
side of the of the
of the bar plot actually being either
deletions
or in sessions here the fact that you
see
more structural variants in pimping
filament the wide relatives compared to
the sunderly contacting modern tomato on
the right hand side
is because we call the svs against the
the reference genome which is a modern
tomato
but eventually there is a huge
distribution of structural variance
within the android automata nodes
we then wanted to know where the
structural variants were
found and what were the genomic features
so what we did and what we are showing
here is
the count of structural
variants grouped for each tomato type
sense
so sp stands for sodium penicillium slc
series forming galapagos many are the
white tomatoes
and sll is the modern solar normally
surrounding copercicle
so what this shows is that structural
variants
are found largely distributed between
value genomic features
and what you look more precisely at
where those structural variants are
found
you've we actually found that they are
mostly for a large proportion of them
found in the antigenic area which is the
pink
about the pink box plot on the right
hand side of the graph
but a very large fraction
also found within the close vicinity of
the gene so either 5kb
upstream of genes which is a green box
plot
or within 5 kb downstream of the genes
which is the purple box so this is
particularly interesting because it
means that
there is a significant enrichment of
structural variant in gene vicinity
where
regulatory sequence
can tend to cluster suggesting that
transposon might have structural
variants might have
an important effect on on gene activity
so we then wanted to know
more about the genetic and the genomic
features of the structural variants
and what we found is actually that
most of the structural variants
identified in our analysis were actually
associated
with transposability 84
of deletions and 76 percent of insertion
detected in our analysis are actually
associated
with repetitive sequence this is huge
that is the main method we want to
convey here is that
transposons are
very major drivers of structural
elevation in the tomato genomes
what i'm showing on the stacked bar
plots on the left-hand side
is actually when you take these 84
percent
of transplant associated dilation and 76
percent of transport associated with
sessions
um what you see is that
at least 50 percent of these
trusses associated structural variants
are actually due
to what we call retrotransposons
retail transposons for the family gypsy
and copia
are translucent elements that have the
ability to
copy and paste themselves within the
genome
and the fact that they make a
significant fraction
of the genome is here particularly
interesting and suggests that
the lcr is the transposons from the
gypsy and copia families are able to
provide important variation within the
genomes
i'm showing here a different
representation of the same data
just to show you that when you are
looking at structural variants that
overlap with
um sequences annotated as transposable
elements
uh you see that copia and gypsy retro
elements
are most already enriched uh in the
associated sequences
suggesting again that copia and gypsy
and tierra
transposons are major drivers of
structural variation in tomato
so we then wanted to know more about uh
the transposon landscape of tomato
and here we took advantage of our 100
tomato genomes
and we actually assembled 14 of them
in order to to to have a more diverse
idea
of the transposon landscape
within those genomes and
what we found which was actually in line
with what was known already from
the current reference genome is that at
least 50 percent
of the tomato genomes we have in our
ends
uh are actually made of transposons and
more than 90 percent of these of these
transportable elements found in tomato
genomes
are ltr transposons either being
gypsy which are the most enriched
industrial transposons in in
tomato but also cochlear elements but
also
strongly influencing the transposon
landscaping tomato
so what we show here is that structural
variation is widespread in tomato
it is found in many different genomic
features
with a strong fraction being found
in promoters and downstream sequence
surrounding genes suggesting that they
might have
important role and effect on gene
activity
and that transposons are major
contributors
to the structural variation and
especially alternative transposon copy
jeeps so because we saw that
we wanted to inquire more
what was the biological relevance of
transposons having
an activity or consequences on gene
action on gene activity
and what could be the phenotypes that
could be influenced by
such activities so that would be the
topic i will be discussing in the second
part of my talk right now
so i will i'm showing you here four
different cases
where phenotypic variation in tomato
is happening on the left-hand side of
the of the slide you can see
a huge variation in tomato fruit shape
and especially in this case a very nice
elongation phenotype that is
that is that is happening in tomato
fruit on the right hand top right hand
side of the
of the slide i'm showing you direction
happening in the structure of the
inflorescence
and particularly where the red star here
denotes actually what we call
a joint so the joint is actually a very
important feature of tomato and
fluorescence
because it allows a fruit drop
when the fruit the tomato food is is
right and mature
uh so in the j2 mutant which is on the
right hand side
uh there's actually a mutation in the
gene aquatic j2
and it actually leads to the loss of uh
the joint which actually avoids the
fruit to drop
which is a very important agronomical
trait that has been selected by raiders
for
decades now bottom left i'm showing you
a very obvious change in fruit color
with lots of function
in the gene that is called yellow flesh
or r and
on the right hand side i'm showing you
phenotypic variation in leaf shape in
tomato
there is actually a common
origin for such large variation within
tomato phenotypes
in every single case this is due
to a change in gene activity due to a
transposon infection
and which is what is very interesting
here is that
for the four cases a transposon from the
same family
is all the time responsible for
uh the changing activity of the gene and
the
translation family involved here and i'm
just highlighting it now
is a transposon family called rider
so we wanted to know more about writer
whereabouts and just to understand
what made ryder such a strong
driver of of you know genetic mutation
and certain driver of structural
variation
with potential strong effect on tomato
filament
so what do we know about ryder well
ryder belongs
uh it's also it's a it's ltr transposon
so it belongs to the copia-like
super family of transposons and it's
actually
[Music]
showing very classical structure with
two uh long terminal repeats ltrs five
front three frames that are flattening
the coding region so the coding region
encodes all the proteins are needed for
the transposon
life cycle and what we know is that
tried are transcribed
in more than tomato but also
in white species related to tomato so
what you can see from
the left hand side is actually a
northern blood showing radar rna
and on the on the right hand side you
can see a
blood showing uh actually obtained using
probes that are actually detecting the
long term that repeats the predator
so what you can see here is that tomato
species and related species
uh are showing uh radar presence in
their genomes
but then when you look at certain number
ozone by example which is potato or then
tobacco or coffee then
radar sequences are not found in the
genomes
so we wanted to know what was the
distribution of rider within the tomato
genomes and to do that
uh we used a sequential g approach and
we denote
annotated um intact rider copies within
the tomato genome using
our dinner one ocean annotation tool
algae prep
and we found 71 full-length spider
copies within the tomato genome
as you can see from this figure
rider copies are found largely dispersed
within the 12 tomato chromosomes being
found
either in highly heterochromatic areas
such as centromeres and pericentromeals
but also in in euchromatic
the age of the transposon
and the time at which the session even
happened
uh can give you an idea about the edge
of the transplant itself
so what i'm showing here as well using
the color code is
the edge of the estimated edge of the of
the transposition event
with based on the similarity between
the two ltr sequences flanking the
particle sequence of the transposon
estimating the edge of its session and
what you can see here that we have a
huge
breath of of age of transposons
with some of them being very young
highlighted here in green
some of them being much older
highlighted here in red
so when we do a phylogenetic analysis on
these 71
integrator copies we actually found a
subpopulation of pride elements that are
evolutionary
young and then thus still very important
for transposition
and on the other side which is about
two-thirds of the rider population
radar elements that are heavily imitated
that are showing lower tier identities
um within the sequences and suggesting
that the scope is
lost their transcriptional and
transpositional potential
we then wanted to know what was
regulating by the activity
so to do that we actually looked at the
sequences
that are contained within the long
terminal repeats so usually transposon
promoters
are contained within their long terminal
repeats
and what we found through sequence
analysis is that
the ltr of right actually harbors
several seafrigato elements that are
usually specific of the hydration
responsive protests
um these trigger treatments such as the
mycorrh
or cb cbf or ab related cis regulator
elements
actually uh you know markers of
of a potential activation by
deiteration so we tested this
possibility and
through a combination of molecular
genetic analysis
we actually found that
environmental factors such as drought
water deprivation
and soil stress were actually able to
activate rider transposition
and it was also interesting to note that
alongside the environmental factors
so plant hormones phytohormones also
have the ability to increase
radioactivity
on the other end we also found
identify repressors of lighter activity
because no having an overly active
transposon within genome can actually
be pretty deleterious right and then
you're seeing a lot of genomic
rearrangement
so we found out that within the tomato
genome it exists the chewing system
that maintains rather activity at a low
level
and it has been found for the
transposons
those repressors are mostly epigenetic
involving gene methylation
monitoring rna and especially here in
this case in the case of rider
plant specific rna polymerase 4 and 5.
we because ryder is so active in in
tomato we wanted to know
if it was uh also found potentially
active
in other related
tomato species and
we looked at the presence of rider
signatures and more
signatures being the sequence of rider
ltrs within
related tomato species such as sonoma
cannon penile and avocado
what this figure shows is that um
in a canon penile and abracapatis
we've been able to detect very highly
conserved ltr
sequences belonging to rider indoor
genomes that are found
here and shown here by the this peak on
the right hand side of the graph
that corresponds to very lightly intact
rider copies
in their genomes what these
figures shows as well is that there is a
huge number
of remnants of rider sequences from
these genomes
that are shown here basically by the
peak on the left-hand side of the figure
and what this says is that there has
been
a strong rider activity in the past
happening also in these genomes
and these bursts of activity
have been very well controlled by the
genomes and now
uh we can see that the sequence are
actually pretty rapidly and losing
homology
when we compare them to the rider
reference sequence
and we then extended our analysis
further away in the plant kingdom and
looked at
right the presence of the sequences in
other crop
genomes and what we found
surprisingly was actually some really
highly conservative sequence
in a large number of crop plants
including here by example radish
or a wild strawberry as well as
beet or a carrot so suggesting that
the uh raider ancestor
was already probably here in the last
command of system before the split that
led to this diversity of fence
and that also suggests that a rider or
rather like sequences have managed to
stay
healthy with these within their genomes
uh despite the presence of a
surveillance system
so with this i would like to put you my
two type take-home messages so from the
first part i showed that the tomato
pan structural variant genomes actually
reveal the extent of the structural
variation we see in tomato species
and we also reveal the impact
of those structural variants on the
genome
and on the second part um i was
interested in transposons because we
showed that transposons
are a main driver structural variation
in tomato
and uh transposons are very likely
uh facilitated the diversification of
phenotypes
they actually transport and underlie a
lot
of phenotypes that are of importance for
breeding and agriculture
so with this i would like to wrap up and
thanks uh
first of all my team and my supervisor
zach which
is an amazing supervisor and gives me a
lot of opportunity with this project
as well as shingang wong and michael
lounge
which are the main authors
on the structural projects
and we also like to thank our amazing
collaborators that made all this
research possible
as well our as our funding
so hhmr oius medical institute as well
as crosstalking hardware leverage
and with this i would like to thank you
for your attention
and i will be happy to take questions
through email thank you